play watch listen is supported by
patreon who actually got this episode
unedited early and AD free if you want
to support the podcast check the link in
the description Hello everyone I'm going
to do the intro at the start of the show
is everybody recording yeah I'm
recording welcome to play watch listen
I'm going to post my video game right
now that's Mike Bethel he's a video game
director that's awesome I'm wearing his
video game composer and that is the
video game actor it's gonna be a short
episode
um Last of Us episode three
came out Sunday night
I did not cry because I we're all tap
into it very tough
um yeah yeah yeah you're cool you're
extremely tough person sucked that tear
back up into those tear Ducks
you know there's something not on my
watch sometimes I watch things and and I
I look at it and I go damn I wish I had
thought of that a story about two people
living alone in an apocalypse who just
fall in love and the way that that plays
out is such a [__] perfect hour or
whatever it was it was
incredible it was so well done that I
was like what a simple premise that is
so pointed to the the what I keep saying
The Last of Us is about which is not
zombies and it's not an apocalypse it's
it's a relationship between two people
and humans and what matters to you I
just thought it was absolutely beautiful
and heartbreaking and uh I didn't know
Nick Offerman was had all that in him
like I like they were both incredible
but like I'm so used to seeing him as
Ron Swanson that I was like holy [__]
dude like
amazing
um top to bottom absolutely adored it
Craig Mason talks about
um Vince Gill Vince Gilligan obviously
with Brian Cranston loves to cast
comedic actors in dramatic roles because
he understands that there's a dramatic
side to them and Craig knew that about
Nick from the from the onset but the
thing that I commend him the most about
and we get into this in the conversation
of the podcast which is
he he said this is a story about
long-term committed relationships and
specifically that long-term committed
relationship between two middle-aged men
so
he said I Craig I am a middle-aged
married man
I can't tell that story but what I can
do is partner with other people who can
help me tell my story he goes you really
got to do your homework he goes so what
do we do we hired Peter horror who's the
director of that episode who's a
middle-aged gay married man super happy
to hear that a cinematographer is a
middle-aged gay married man our editor
was a middle-aged gay married man it's
like we are literally putting this
through that lens because we want to get
it right
and that is why I feel like they did was
because the the desire was not to now
let's do a gay episode it didn't come
across that way at all at all I could
show that to any
I could I could show that I think to the
staunchest Evangelical Christian who at
least had an open heart and go tell me
that's not love
tell me you know what I that that's not
a perfect example of it what it struck
me as also watching it was
um
you know I sometimes
uh folks will there's the the recurring
accusation is that a story like that is
kind of ham-fisted in just to just for
the sake of it and I found myself
thinking that in the context of the
story of the collapse of
the world and of people and particularly
the idea that
the story as a whole is about Joel
finding and embracing his purpose
um like like as like the last of us
being about that and this being a little
kind of bottle episode that
gives us somebody else
to use as our Joel stand in in a way
until this whole other thing we are it
still ends with the the note being like
hey this is the kind of menu oh it's so
pushes it to him yeah and and and I I
listened to the the podcast that Troy
did with Neil and Craig and it's so I so
recommend it there's a lot of really
fascinating and Powerful insights but I
actually found that
what I was going to say was that the
thing that struck me was that the idea
that
um
that for Bill
it's it's it's sort of a coming out of
sorts story and that that that's
actually that's actually that serves the
idea of discovering one's purpose far
better than if it was
a conventional straight romance every
single detail if it's a middle-aged you
know straight relationship story it
could have been very powerful but there
was something about somebody
having to kind of simultaneously Embrace
multiple realities that they're
initially uncomfortable with and then
completely finding themselves in that
that it made it land so much harder it
was one of those where I said you can't
you cannot I can't see the argument that
this is somehow inorganic to the larger
narrative like I can see that I can see
that complaint and whether I agree or
not I can understand it in certain cases
when I see certain shows or movies or
whatever people will go like it felt
like they were ticking a box we need a
gay character or we needed this or that
I think that there are sometimes I go
you know look I can see that I I don't I
don't necessarily agree or it didn't
bother me but I could see how it might
look that way if you're kind of looking
through that land but in this case boy
did I not feel that way it was just like
someone who was better for this as
someone who is not straight
there are absolutely like movies and TV
shows where I go that felt inorganic
that felt like you did that in order to
get that audience or to get that
reaction that does exist we can't
pretend that doesn't exist in this case
not even a little bit like you're right
that I think it it suits never mind that
it is in the original also just in a
very difference which yeah someone uh
there have been a lot of comments flying
about that I was like it can't be they
made this change they're like they
didn't they did that with part two they
made Ellie gay like oh you didn't play
Left Behind come on
did you when you were on on the podcast
did you get into the changes that were
made like in terms of like making it
more like positive representation was
that something that was like an
intentional choice or
Parts they were they were happier couple
in them in the show than they are in the
all of these implied in the game right
yeah one of those things like something
that was work through I'm just
interested not a negative way I [__]
loved the episode but I'm just
interested in the kind of the process
Craig wanted to show the relationship
and the Arc of the relationship and
for speaking us into what you talked
about the the issue of purpose where
literally that is what
bill says to him at the very end was
that I am old I'm satisfied and you were
my purpose and that's just yeah what a
what an amazing summation of that entire
article it's about being a more
satisfying kind of yeah it's like we
lived come on well it's about tying in a
theme right like nobody stays together
for 20 years
if there's not some good moments if
there's not good times oh yeah no for
sure for sure
it was my worst days ever have been with
you because I love that that was also
listed there and is a really reality of
a long-term relationship um I'm not
gonna say that every day was a gift I
love that and he's holding his hand as
he says it to but there's been far more
better days
and that that to me and also I love the
notion that
there is this
even through all of that that there was
never a moment that where they said even
as just a couple bottles of wine too
many or whatever the the the necessities
of of convention like getting married no
longer apply but that there is this
still this like there's one more thing
we got to do and if we're going to go
out or if I'm gonna go out I want to go
out like this and it's just there's not
a single thing that they missed on this
one so much so even starting from the
very beginning some other stuff got
pointed out the fact that
uh there's been this long-running
mystery and kind of like people that
that love to dig deep into the lore of
how where the
um where the quarter steps first broke
out
not the location but like what caused it
and there was this theory about the
bread Theory or the bread conspiracy
that's so fast right it was cool and
there's something that Joel glosses over
very quickly is that he explains this
most people think it's a flower and you
put that in what something that
everybody has well what were the two
things on day one that he was supposed
to have
pancakes for breakfast and a birthday
cake and they couldn't right no he
forgot it he forgot to get the pancakes
and he forgot to get the cake I didn't
notice that that's a lovely idea they
came this close to Joel being and Sarah
being along with everybody else so the
the thing to me that I love about that
is is it's very easy for us to look at
our mistakes as failures and sometimes
our mistakes lead us to a different path
but they could clearly in this story uh
lead us closer to our true purpose can I
ask uh Troy I'm not sure if you know the
answer this is one thing in this episode
that I wasn't sure about that like I've
never had more faith that a show will
address or answer to every question I
have than I do right now I'm like you've
got this don't worry about it but
um the Ellie choosing to cut open
the um clicker yeah what was that about
she's violent
she has a violent heart and that will be
um her violence in Joel's vulnerability
to me are the two things that are
in one side of the scale that are
constantly in play with each other
and you see that from the very beginning
when in episode one Joel beats the [__]
out of that guy out of the federal dude
she leans in and looks and she wants to
see versus what Sarah did which was she
was catatonic she was traumatized by
seeing the violence of something that
was clearly intent on hurting them and
instead of being proud of her dad going
thank you for protecting me she was like
what the [__] did you do
so and what is Ellie constantly asking
for give me a gun I want a gun I want a
gun and this is someone who huh like I
would have given out of God I keep being
like there is a whole wall
the circumstances
maybe there'd be a Last of Us Part three
you know pitch that story I think for me
as a dad it's the thing that
um I don't want my failures to be uh
passed down to traveler in any way right
and so sometimes what that can lead to
are aversions
um I to the things that I had that
happened to me when I was a kid was like
uh almost drowned a couple times and I
have choked and so the two things that
I'm terrified for traveler are those two
things and so but that doesn't mean I
keep them out of the pool but I've I've
been very I will strap floaties around
that kid's body every which way I can
just to keep them afloat and what that's
what that's for me that's fully
self-serving because what I'm trying to
do is satisfy my fears as opposed to do
what I should do which is we need to
teach you how to swim and we need to
teach you to have Awareness on the water
and we need to teach you how to get rid
of your choking what do you do so I
think that's what we're seeing with Joel
is I failed in this
and I could have protected her and my
daughter got shot and so what I'm going
to do is make sure that I don't ever put
her around a gun if I don't have to and
somehow he feels like he can handle a
gun but that she can't yeah
but I gotta bounce because I have a call
starting now yeah
play on the keyboard
McDonald's
it's a Scottish person he's like I'm
sorry Hamburglar you're muted
um how could I list that many characters
from McDonald's that's a hell of a
universe the other thing that obviously
this episode changes I mean it changes
it's it's been it's
frustrating I don't want to address it
um it's either that he was a side
character and it didn't matter so why
was it a whole episode or he was super
important so why did you change it but
um both of those arguments are stupid
obviously
they're just uninformed
and it's honestly there is so simply
because we could no I could say I could
say they're stupid because I'm not
related anyway because I can say this
it's an adaptation things were changed
because um
and Troy kept racing me for this episode
you kept me like episode three and it
genuinely is one of the best episodes TV
ever like I I thought it was just so
it's hard beautiful
um episode the television where I could
just drop you into you don't have to
know anything about this I agree I just
go watch this if you if you do go back
and watch one and two watches that would
be one hell of a movie it was mad dude
it does like on the on the on the
representation aspect like
obviously a completely different thing
but like it's so rare to see a long-term
relationship represented I realized this
I was watching it like as someone who's
you know I've been with Kerry 18 years
like that's I'm nearly at the Tipping
Point of spend more more of my life with
her than without yeah like
I was 18. oh
you're 42.
oh Ultra
you had me for like a split second
the joy that Springs
of Joy go ahead sorry
but no I was just saying like it's it's
it's something that actually genuinely
watching I was like I don't I don't get
to see the kind of relationship I have
like in in TV shows that often my old
movies because like it's not because
it's usually considered not very
interesting right like you know no one
wants to see a boring story about two
people who love each other very much I
think but this shows how you can do that
and how you can put an interesting spin
on it and and contextualize it I thought
it's beautiful they also broke some
rules in terms of kill your gaze
and uh what's the other one there was
something else that I was like there's a
thing to do oh well there's like there's
some some rules that you're not supposed
to break that I think like if you try
and play
too safely Within
lines oh you don't take risks with
storytelling like having Side characters
be the focus of a whole episode would be
breaking a rule of a of a convention
um killing a gays in terms of two gay
people dying or something you're not
supposed to do all these like it's a
cliches I think killing your games is
totally upset it is not here well it's
used often and it drives me nuts like
it's the same as a woman sexually
assaulted and that that's herak to
become a badass be accused those kind of
things or any of the that's the thing is
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot of
very there's a lot of things that have
been handled lazily in the past and
avoiding them now right and some people
are doing them well let's just not do it
let's just not do it um but what I love
about Craig and Neil is that and and
specifically speaking to that Trope uh
they lean into it and that's why bill
says this isn't the tragic end this
isn't the tragic suicide at the end of
the play well that's part of it too is a
romanticizing suicide again a lot of
rules broken but they're not breaking in
the way that I think is the problem
leaning into it probably was the best
course like let's acknowledge what's
happening here let's acknowledge what to
happen in this world this is what you do
and again I think that the intention
behind it most people will do that for
sensationalism purposes yeah
um it was a shortcut to a gut punch and
what Craig was doing was like no I'm
gonna lean into this and go this is not
what this is all right and and to be
almost he could turn to camera and say
that down the lens and say I know what
you're thinking that I'm doing and I'm
not doing those things
I think that the the term representation
I can't speak to the gay relationship
but what I can speak to is
representation of exactly what Mike was
talking about like what does a committed
relationship look like and that
representation that whole layer of
representation was so accurately
depicted as well where you go from this
moment of intimacy and the first sexual
encounter smash cut to oh [__] you you
know exactly to me was and it's it's not
a it shows brilliantly edited and I feel
like that's the thing really and that
[__] is like I know where we need to go
from here I I do want to speak a little
bit too
um again to the the incredible
production design
um so much of like it's it's been lauded
that this is like the most expensive
show that HBO's ever done and it's easy
to look at that and go I don't
understand how
everything goes up on the camera you
know up on the screen
um and that town they built
and what's incredible is there are no
roofs
on those houses oh they built it up to
this level that's all the effects yeah
so it makes sense I it didn't to me I'm
looking this going what what I never
would have guessed and they're like oh
that's all VFX because first of all it's
too expensive takes too much time and we
can't light we can't move cameras inside
that house we can't do anything that we
need to do and we're going to go inside
that house so here's what we need to do
and so at the coast so the Interiors are
also it's all one set like you're in the
exterior and then that's that literally
leads directly into an interior yeah
because like that shot of him walking
out the front door or of course
you know normally you'd film The
Interiors in one set and then you do
your extra that's wild that part that's
genuinely impressive but I was I I did I
hadn't watched the second episode where
I mean talked last
um I caught up on it
um and I was I wanted to say it say to
you Troyer because it was it was just an
amusing thing where I was like I was
watching it and I was like oh I know
this I know this I've been to this
Museum I've been to this this Museum in
Boston and I have been to Boston less
than once I've been to a museum but then
going to that museum it took me a good
like five minutes to be like no you're
remembering playing the game
you're like you're remembering this is
like I've been in here I think it was in
the University of Eastern Colorado once
I believe I visited that school but it
was just this moment of like but that
was just that was just for me that was
fun because yeah that sense of reality
that sense of like I think this is a
place the way it looked blew my mind but
also after I played part two and then I
went to Seattle again I was like like
the whole city feels really different
once you've been there and I had that
when I first came to L.A too I was like
holy [__]
because it's been you 've seen it so
many times in so many things
and yeah if I'm on to this day I'm still
this way we'll be driving like on the
one coming up from Santa Monica back
home or whatever and like we passed this
one there's the Malibu Pier and I look
at that I'm just like
GTA yeah I know exactly where I'm at
right now in GTA I also do the entrance
ramp so one of the first skaters I don't
remember which which Tony Hawk game it
is but you like grind on that Santa
Monica Pier yeah I'm always like I know
exactly where I am right now yeah but I
don't think I've ever seen it done from
I don't think I've ever had that
experience watching a like an adaptation
from games
you know they're a good there are good
adaptations and stuff but like all ones
that have done a good job of reproducing
the visuals but that was the first time
I had to set a real sense of like
familiarity with the space with the
geography of it that was intriguing and
it's it's not about authenticity it was
just about it captures it's really doing
a great job of capturing and bringing
forth what what worked in the game for
us it looks incredible that's very
interesting I feel like the sets and
it's it's unbelievable like it's we've
said it feels familiar but also elevated
we've said for a while like this is like
the best time for television like
there's so many like televisions where
it's at what I feel has happened
literally in the last
couple of years even even somewhat so in
the last year is there have been lessons
that have been gleaned from what
television what's happening inside of
the ecosystem of Television that have
impacted the way that we look at content
view content uh like like literally the
way that we consume it there are the way
that we examine it after we've viewed it
um and I think that this is
I I would I would put this out to
anybody who's making something right now
the reason why
this is successful is because it is 100
devoted to doing something with
Excellence rather than carrot on a stick
worm on a hook bait and there's an easy
trap to fall into right now of
sacrificing quality or sacrificing
Integrity in order for I don't even know
that I would think we're in a great
state for television and I think again I
don't watch a lot of good TV it's my own
fault but um that the loss of us is
standing out to me for that reason and
standing out to me is like you know the
I the pot with the uh in Chicago the
scientist who's in the morgue and I was
like any other network that would have
been a jump scare and I was like this is
HBO they're not going to do that that's
cheesy why on Earth would you do that
but I was like if this were any other
show they probably would have jump
scared us in that moment but this isn't
what the show is doing and I think
episode right well once you do it just
scare you lose tensions yeah you lose
tension if you do the jump scare so
that's a setup for the tension so you
don't want to let the tension off so you
keep the tension
um but I think like episode three are
right in terms of Excellence is like
again I I appreciate the breaking of
rules the rules are arbitrary it's so
many things that so many other people
given the storyline would never have
done that they wouldn't have had that
episode focus on these two people who
aren't the two main characters they
wouldn't have have done a million things
that they did there and the fact that it
was executed so confidently and so just
like this is what we're doing this is
what this story is I just I just thought
it was just again one of the worst
episodes TV I've ever seen it also
though what I thought was really
impressive and this speaks to the the
editing side as well like it also though
I'd seen obviously I'd seen people
reacting to it and I I knew enough about
you know the story that I was like okay
so this is going to be the special
episode this is gonna be that episode of
Mythic Quest this could be that episode
of you know where you you go after some
this is your Awards episode it's about
Awards episode yeah but but well so that
was what I went in thinking but it
there's some travel in terms of the
storytelling with Joel and Ellie that I
was genuinely surprised by I thought we
weren't gonna get like those characters
there's a there's the the there it works
both as a bottle you've got that bottle
episode but that's like that's like 50
minutes of the episode it's also using
that as a moment of catharsis for the
tests Fallout you know it's we're using
that as as a it's all it's almost using
that as like a fable to process Joel's
feelings dealing with divergences
feelings about that like it's it's
pulling a lot of moves there and then
you've also got the stuff with Ellie and
then yeah foreshadowing of future
relationships I presume without like
there's just a lot of stuff there that's
very cleverness of How It's placing that
it's not just going to one side and
going here's uh hey uh hey hey his award
Emmys look look Offerman he's he's good
he's good you like you like him doing
it's it is it he is very good but it's
also propelling our protagonist yeah
which I thought was that's a very clever
Balancing Act I would definitely
um encourage people to go back and watch
it one of the reasons why is Pamela are
watching it Sunday night and
um when starts by the river and Joel is
stacking the Rocks she was like I I
forgot like I remember it starting
with
the whole underground not today you Jack
boot [__] uh which by the way was Craig
wrote that in the parentheticals of the
stage Direction just to kind of like let
the actor know this is kind of what bill
is thinking and he does that in his
writing and Craig does a much better job
of Nick Offerman but Nick was basically
like just let you know I'm saying that
line so that was originally just
internal internal monologue or internal
dialogue rather
um but uh there's a lot that I think
people will miss exactly what you're
talking about as far as there's a lot of
ground traveled with Joel and Ellie in
the beginning and the end
that is definitely worthy of there's the
wonderful arcade moment that happens and
the very beginning there's the great
Revelation and further delving into
Ellie's violent side so definitely go
back through and you'll just expect
you're going to cry again because I did
just as much the second time as I did
the first time which speaks to the
profundity and the beauty of of the
episode but yeah that's the the one
thing I think I said this last week that
I'm still like again with full faith in
the in the project entirely that I'm
still like Ellie's so mean in this
version I feel like she's so much nicer
in the game because I'm playing them
side by side
um but I was like writing for TV and
writing for games are two very very
different things you have to very
differently and I'm like if her if she
has to have an awk but we see her go on
this journey you can't have the arc
start on episode three it's too soon and
I'm like I'm also she functions in the
gameplay in the game like you have to
have care about throwing you stuff you
have but you you have to have her she
has to feel like a someone you're
protecting and someone who's protecting
you that yeah they it's that that thing
in video games writing which which even
something like Last of Us which which
pushes the writing toward more
television let's say and I mean that's a
compliment in this televisual just in
terms of its very opposite episode like
Last of Us is clearly written in kind of
Last of Us is written a bit like a HBO
show which I think is one of the reasons
it's kind of translating well and it
allows for that that thing yeah what I'm
saying is most games writing
um it's all fun and games so like in in
the classic kind of write it all the all
the how to write screenplays books fun
and games is like the bit in the middle
of your movie which uh you've seen all
the trailers right it's the that second
act and video games are all second act
you have to kind of basically in in
traditional game storytelling you can
press your First Act to next to nothing
of like hey here's the Space Marine and
I guess he wants to save the princess
and that's your entire first down yeah
then your entire game is two acts I
don't think
there is a yeah no it doesn't but my
point is that's the entire point I'm
making which is in terms of like
relationship development you kind of you
have to rush even in something like Last
of Us you you you have to make Ellie
warm to Joel faster than you would in a
TV show where you can actually linger
you can you can have the audience be
like Ellie seems like a bit of an
[__] for like a few episodes and
that's okay because there's time for
that to breed where he's appreciated I
have to get to the points a little
faster totally no yeah you have to care
about her you have to be willing to
escort her because you are doing it
yourself she has to help you it's yeah
and last of us the game is so well
written that that is kind of made to
feel natural and made to feel good and
and still has that emotional Arc but
it's almost like they it by by necessity
of the medium you know the writer has to
kind of speed up that opening just a
little bit more and I think the show is
allowing that just a bit more time to
breathe yeah than you do in the game
that's that's my opinion but it's like
it's it's definitely uh a writing
challenge I'm sure you come across this
a lot like
because the verbs of a game are go to
place and do a thing like it doesn't
leave a lot of room sometimes
at SMS for
two and a half years now and I every day
I learn more and more that um creative
writing on video games actually it's
across the board I'm like writing a
screenplay right now as well it's not
that creative it is but it's very
technical writing in general I think is
a lot more technical than when I was
writing short stories
so this can be here like we're watching
Sopranos right now I'm watching Sopranos
for the first time on episode 10. and
they're technically brilliantly written
so many technical choices all the time
that I'm like oh they've done that so
that this can happen later and I'm just
seeing it more now than I probably did
before I started working in AAA but it's
it's so that's why the whole I
definitely subscribe to the school of
thought that act structures are bollocks
but they're useful they're they're
they're essentially what you know is it
a three x factories of five x structures
or whatever in reality that's just
causality that's just sequences of
helping you organize pieces yeah yeah
but honestly you could you could write a
book about how every movie is a 13 act
structure and it would still be a useful
resource because of course thinking
about what that is yeah and it's it's
hilarious when you people take it very
take those things very literally which
is a very kind of to me that's something
that everyone kind of does at the start
of their writing career and then what
you realize is yeah exactly as you say
it's set up some payoffs and Rule of
three it's it's just it's useful these
these all of these shorthands are useful
because they just force you to think
about causality and setups and payments
and so much of video games there's like
a lot of um
how do we make sure the player and the
protagonist align and how do we make
sure that the player feels the same way
about this as this and like how do we
make sure like how is the player gonna
react to this it's so much of that plus
scope like so much of and now we have
four escapism no okay scope is sometimes
the question is how can we pull the
player towards wanting what we need them
to want right now
don't even get me started on that I I
the whole thing is like well why are we
there because we need them to be there
yeah because it costs five million
dollars if they can go in that direction
instead we just need to have them come
here you need to change your game I do
not realize how expensive things were
like and that's still something that I'm
still figuring out every day is like
this not cost too much got it okay I
think that's the I think the thing that
the question I would ask and probably
will hopefully get a chance to ask him
at some point
um
I I maybe you've maybe you've had this
conversation try I would love to know
from his perspective what what having 10
years as a gap has allowed in terms of
because the idea that you could
basically have your story out there have
everyone react to it see what that is
and then kind of go back to the blank
page you're singing in the show like
you're you're literally I'm interested
in what that process was and what that
kind of and what and where he would
place the focus where he would say well
actually I feel like I really learned
this as a writer yeah because there's no
way like there's no way he'd be
but it's like the same person you also
never stop improving like I had a
conversation with someone the other day
where they were like oh this person's my
age and they're way more successful than
me I'm way more talented I'll never get
there and I was like what's your age got
to do with it you could still go to
school and learn so even if if Neil was
amazing 10 years ago he's still gotten
better in it definitely like that never
that doesn't end I don't think
comparison is the thief of Joy uh
official but it is also a great metric
like time and and distance from
something is is the metric and this is
the other thing that I think is making
no not think no that is making this show
successful is that who is in charge who
is at the helm are two people that are
the most passionate people about telling
this story than anybody else on the
planet and as is the case with every
video game company known for good
storytelling
that's true but it's awesome video game
company that anyone would name as like
oh they're really good story it's all
there's always a writer in charge or
very close very story first studio and
and the struggle with this power yeah
he's he's literally the person that
could go at any desk at naughty dog and
go move and sit down and do it and
that's a rarity but I think that Neil
and the conversations between he and
Craig of Craig Owen in so much uh Craig
points I said he goes this is another
result of one of my pesky questions of
like why is fedra in the outskirts
why why do why do you have them
attacking tests in episode two wouldn't
that be clickers and Neil's like yeah
because we needed to do this he was like
great okay well we don't need to do that
so yeah so had Craig played The Last of
Us
Pria like like a long time ago oh or was
it oh yeah okay so I saw the impression
he was a fan this is what's so but it's
nice to have him as like a person who's
worked on TV come in and be like hey
questions about this but even then he
sold he's in the engineering analogy
he's he's this is a place
so he's pulling this stuff over and he's
working out how to reconfigure it says
here is the art medium right and and
this is this is what everybody obviously
was like well yeah just if we could do
that that'd be great everyone it's the
the the Arc of it is this will you
please make my thing
and then someone goes ooh we want to
make your thing and then the other
person goes this is the thing I want to
make and the other people go we want to
make whatever you want to make so the
fact that you know when The Last of Us
came out and we've already talked about
this is like there's no other video game
that when the seeking of the adaptation
occurred only one game had come out
never that had never happened everything
was always a franchise hmm that was like
Tomb Raider Halo anything there had been
a franchise established Assassin's Creed
Uncharted all of those were established
franchises before the adaptation was
sought Last of Us One game we want to
make that and the process of going is it
a movie well I don't know why don't you
write the script oh this doesn't work is
it this director that's attached to it
we're not sure can't do it can't do it
can't do it it falls away finally not
only that Craig Mason who's an
incredibly accomplished uh established
writer gets a success gets a win
Chernobyl he's now you know poster boy
for HBO and they go what do you want to
make and he goes you get me anything
that I want to make it's going to be I
want to do this story can we get it oh
it happened that way yes Shannon it was
his it was his Inception it was his I
can do anything I want to do lots of us
that's really interesting but that's the
other thing it's not so much hey we want
to pitch this to HBO
HBO was like what do you what do you
want to do we'll give you anything you
want to do and he and Neil had just had
lunch
and Shannon Woodward who played Dina
um and last was part two really like her
she's great she would love you you guys
y'all's humor is very similar I
she's acquainted yeah she's really cool
and a brilliant writer too
um she says in here Craig friend meet
Neil friend you guys go do stuff
together so they go have lunch and Neil
said what would you do and Craig goes
this is what I would do and so Neil goes
I like this what do we do next and Craig
says we go across the street and we go
to HBO and they did and they went over
there it's like hey uh and Neil said I
get I got to sit back and watch if
somebody else pitched my thing it didn't
say a word and Craig he's like did a
great job of pitching it and before they
left the room HBO goes well what do we
need to do to get in business together
and that's how the show was made that's
amazing that is phenomenal it is truly
phenomenal it never happens that way
there's 70 pitches right that's the
thing like I think that's something
people really multiple Studios yeah
every like oh my God the number of times
like working John Wick I had to repitch
John Wick yeah
a room where everyone was the same but
one person had changed like Gary there
is a reason that every single movie has
like someone planning a presentation
because that's all Hollywood is it's a
series of presentations that's really
cool it's I I just have so much faith in
HBO and again like like you said if
we're in a good ERA for TV again I know
I'm not watching a lot of good TV I've
not seen succession I'm not watching
Yellowjackets I haven't seen Whitewater
this is all this stuff that I know
exists that I haven't seen White Lotus
season one's gonna hit a little bit
different to you because you watch this
first yeah
oh this is Frank the early years
this is the live prank left by yeah
holy [__] I don't know what's happening
which seems oh sorry but I also the guy
who plays Frank is In White lyrics
and I am I am moved he's brilliant I am
moved by Murray Bartlett so much so that
I was he was not at the premiere and I'm
kind of glad because I don't think I
would have been able to get my [__]
together he's amazing yeah I mean he's
he's a buff they're both fantastic it's
both incredible choices
um but yeah I feel like this is like the
amount of faith that I have in in what
HBO does while also watching Through The
Sopranos is like yeah there is some
goddamn good TV you also watch there
there are can you go back to Oz right
where it's four by three shitty cameras
HBO
Deadwood and Boardwalk I've watched I've
watched both of those toys RV and
McShane telling me Deadwood production
stories was like the best it is
happening baby of course Dallas did I
tell you that we got the he um he he was
in the booth Troy he was demanding that
he read your lines because your lives
were better than his he was like I
wanted to be this guy you play this
character in the movie it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
who is he I would have walked in and be
like I did ask he did ask who's playing
this role I was like oh Troy Baker he is
never heard of him doesn't matter
[Music]
I think he's beautiful I think I've said
this before but uh Westwood does this
thing where the monologues always have
action and that's I I sometimes read
screenplays for people Westwood or
Westworld
sorry we're dead
um they were shot on the same set dead
World in Westwood it does this thing
where all the monologues have action in
and I I read screenplays with people
sometimes and I it's very easy to do it
for games where I'll like give them tips
or something before they enter a
competition that was the error of sex
position as well right that was the I
don't know that was the term that was
used
so you you do your Exposition during a
sex scene which was very Game of Thrones
Rome the monologues that Ian McShane had
whilst oh they didn't say it's an
amazing world
it's so good
um because they're so it's so easy to
like so many again Junior screenplays
really do this and it's just two people
sitting in a room and then they go and
they sit at home and I'm always like hey
could this scene be happening because
she's neurotic and this is an anxiety
thing could she be cleaning during this
or like can we think of something to
wait make the action tie into what's
happening sometimes you've got a limited
Indie budget and you have to get the
circular game made and the characters
just have to say subsurface
um but I think like the way that they do
it in
dead wood there you go I keep thinking
I'm sure I've seen I keep forgetting is
is so like someone is cleaning someone
is getting a [__] there are so many
things that happen while they're evoking
emotions that are directly tied to the
character is that I think about it all
the time of the exact choice of action
and how it ties to the monologue because
I'm not actually a huge fan of
monologues in general despite loving
Shakespeare it's something that like I
think we can it takes me out of a person
sometimes if they don't feel like
something that a human would actually
deliver and say but if you have them in
an action sometimes I rant when I'm in
an action and I just I think that that
show specifically is like okay what
would they be doing and how does it
apply to video games it also typically
for actors will all of a sudden they
have nowhere to to Channel all that
energy and so it just ends up being
bigger performances oh that's
interesting to carry actually it kind of
you can almost have like an anxious
performance that they they are going too
far because
in their hands it's like I have
something to do so everything is being
found
of performances I didn't like they're
too big people who aren't they're too
big but they're not doing anything at
the same time that's interesting can you
tell me that you're in despair without
running your fingers through your hair
[__] like that
um the strudel scene in Inglorious
Bastards it's like can we give you a
focus point that is diegetic right so
like the actors the characters are
focused on something that you are too
this is something that that Neil and
Craig
um I'm not sure if they coined the
phrase but I'm going to give them the
the credit for it emotional action
scenes and as we get further into the
story especially in episode six
um you'll see some of the biggest
emotional action scenes
um where for thinking about emotional
action scenes and you keep not watching
rrr and that's just I think because I
think you need help RR I'm going on a
flight is it literally the letters uh
letters RR because it's basically the
origin of the name is that there's
there's essentially two of the biggest
stars and that is it I think it's
tallywood I might be saying that wrong
but a specific film industry of the
Rhode Island tally Woods
it's not a Bollywood film it's often
called a Bollywood film because that's
kind of the western kind of way of yeah
this thing doesn't exist look I I'm glad
you wrote a script oh it's but you know
it's it's called the story I need to say
this because it's the best thing ever
the movie is called RR because there is
a director with the surname beginning
with r and two of the biggest stars in
that Cinema are their names
it would be like if Spielberg directed a
film starring I mean skg so like
Spielberg katzenberg Geffen exactly like
that but with much less profits the
DreamWorks that's amazing
what is it where am I gonna find this
we're doing a plug in the UK it's on
Netflix all right
annoyingly it's just the Hindi what do
you mean annoyingly it's just the Hindi
version
it's not filmed in Hindi it's filmed in
um a different language which I'm
forgetting the name of embarrassingly
was this Hindi that's the handy dub
that's the Hindi dub it wasn't recorded
in Hindi oh that's actually a massive
controversy that Netflix have released
the Hindi version on there rather than
the original
um you know has caused some some local
frustrations but it's very good and
definitely don't watch it in English
um but uh it's brilliant it's beautiful
and it is full of emotional action
scenes I love that and it's something
that I think I feel very strongly about
uh in video games not across the board I
think I love games that have cinematic
cutscenes but I personally am a very big
advocate for if we can uh
show a relationship or tell a story
during action I'm going to opt to do
that over a cutscene and I think that's
just like also a fun and challenging
experiment that watching this stuff and
even watching lots of his TV show and
seeing action
and how relationships develop during
action is something that I think is is
very fun to explore more and more like
how do you how do you make sure that the
player can engage in something while
having an emotional scene that doesn't
end up with a half-life they just jump
around while they're locked in a room
it's um yes it's an interesting it's
probably my favorite challenge
um and it's part of I think narrative
design that is very very very
interesting is how do we make sure that
players can still play something without
because I think especially now people
keep pulling their phones up instead of
watching a cutscene like how do we make
them continue to play while still
keeping them super emotionally engaged
where that's starting to happen is I
mean naughty dot had in-game cinematics
Naughty Dog Hey you Miss Westworld
things are on all the time Vivian
Westwood I say the wrong way all the
time have you I was gonna sorry you're
about to go sorry no I was just gonna
say most people
um are trying to find a way to keep the
player on the stick in some way can we
can we narrative eyes and or make that a
cinematic moment but still keep the
player have agency and I think that
there is a point to that I think there
is something cool however
I was talking to director about this the
other night it was like you know we want
to shoot this like a play I'm like it's
not a play if there's a camera
and that's a that's a trap that people
fall into whereas if you want to have a
play go do a play
um and you can do welcome to dogville
and you can just like put it up on a
stage but Eve the second that you put a
camera on it it's a movie and and that's
okay but you are directing the audience
to be there and if you're going to do
that you better know how to fill that
frame and if you don't and you want to
do it haphazardly and you fix your tools
afterwards there's challenges to that
there's also freedom in that but there's
also a lot of challenges to that have a
lot of work that's interactive in terms
of like I I like I think you're most
associated with a lot of really great
kind of performance capture work
but are you have you done much in the
way of like I mean interactive in the
sense of like recording different
dialogue strings and path obviously
you've got this coming up with the
musical game we've done do you do you
think that's the the future of this
stuff I I definitely no I think that's a
question
so you don't I yeah by the way I think
those are great I think branching
dialogue is great whether you play Mass
Effect or I was clearly a huge fan of
The Telltale that to me is how we've
definitely like we've definitely kind of
pivoted as a company towards that a bit
more just because
essentially I I got bored as a game
creator kind of constantly giving you
just like something to watch instead of
playing so making it an interactive
conversation definitely kind of yeah
agency is the currency and so what we're
trying to do in games right now is give
players more agency however most people
just give branching dialogue but that
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
giving them agency
yeah we're just going to come back to
this anyway so the second that you show
anybody can look behind the hood and go
oh this is just plywood then you
shouldn't have done that just tell your
story and and places or games like the
last of us or whatever are great
examples of just tell your story and do
it well and people will be satisfied
with it you don't have to give them even
a wide linear path you can just go no
you're on Rails this is where we're
going [__] inside dude you're on
Rails but it's a brilliant view also
plywood that's just a different that's
just
less plywood but better focus plywood I
guess is what you're saying yeah go deep
down a really good job of a specific
illusion rather than just like yourself
what Dame did a really [__] good job
of that
um it takes two
and they did a really good job of it's
not dialogue choices it's a relationship
between two characters and they are
having to solve problems together while
going on that journey and the way that
they did it I think is like they have a
million mini games like I'm more
fascinated by how they the literally how
the producers on that game worked than
most games how did you make that many
different systems like it's so
impressive I just want to sit down and
talk to them and be like how did you do
how as much as why right yeah like it
works no absolutely but just in terms of
like the I always think of the kind of
the first meeting on a lot of things
like that pitch what was the decision
let's go back to pitches that must have
been tricky whilst it's very very
impressive though and yeah I agree with
Trey and then I I don't I like dialogue
choices in some cases I think that they
they serve a purpose but I don't think
at all I'm interested in what I'm
interested in is whether there is a
hybrid that's going to emerge I think so
I think a situation where where we can
have something as directed as what
you're talking about Troy by in terms of
it has a you know the camera is pointing
in specific direction to tell a specific
story but still has the agency on the
player I don't think we've cracked that
yet but it seems like there's
something's going to come down the river
um and probably honestly you two are
both I think more likely to find it just
because you're you're working in the
spaces that have the budget and the
space to kind of innovate it's always
going to be led by expense yeah it's the
people who can afford to be the last
leaders right so I think that it's going
to take Triple A in order for that it's
the same thing we're dealing with right
now like the tools that are in the hands
of the the triple layer of and the super
Indie are were forged from the mountains
of the AAA
Indy before I've never had no I'm
my mate Paul genuinely coined the phrase
triple I sarcastically and has regretted
it ever since it's a massive message but
I super Indie I've not heard before
what's super Indie man like we're like
Publishers
we have to beg epic we have the big
Stadium
do I have to work work towards being a
super Indian our our escalator only
comes on vinyl I already are super
indeed I don't know we're actually only
available on SNES
you're you're not a Troy super Indie but
you might be a super Indie you're a
super Indie
um I I think that's all the validation I
need
I'm sorry for the week now but I think
you know I think a lot of innovation
comes out of Indies like like something
like inscription could never be made
I think it comes out of Indies in a
different direction I think right it's
very limited like me and Troy talk a lot
about like you know about I think I feel
like that's that's we talk a lot about
kind of upcoming things and like oh
Mikey didn't are you doing performance
capture for your next game and most of
the time my answer just has to be
nowhere probably below the threshold for
that financially yeah I don't think
financially but like what what does it
benefit you because I'm saying we're a
little system of like because the stuff
yeah to put it really bluntly I I'm
excited to see the the future of stuff
that requires performers like Troy
involved in it and that stuff is going
to be in the AAA space that's that's my
point there's a there's a threshold to
uh to finding this hybrid and it's there
is a financial threshold in this yeah
but I think it's going to apply the
other side of that Hitchcock applies
here too where it's like if all else
fails use dialogue like can you tell
again I go back to Insight can you tell
your story without a single line of
dialogue if you have to have them talk
there better be a good [__] thing
they say but if you base your premise on
well we're a dialogue driven game like
[__] have you ever played tunic
started to I I love the the like the
language stuff in there not even really
in English yeah that is a game that
doesn't have a tutorial that like I
there were parts of it where I was
finding it too hard because I hadn't
picked up a certain page that would tell
you
how to level up so I didn't know you
could modern players will never
understand how how how hard it is to do
tutorial either doing tutorial without
text I'm not a good enough game designer
incredible I I want to do a game that
has no tutorialization and no HUD like
no no it does have a UI witness doesn't
have UI
um
this is like all you I right like it's
UI technically the whole name
right that's UI but like if you have
like this cool diegetic UI I think
that's awesome
Dead Space is it on Steam deck
I want to play it because I'm hearing
great things I'm also Craig recommended
a game there is no game
I haven't heard of that it's neither did
I it's stuck on the radar but it's it's
on the old deckies I gotta go yeah I do
too but I was also gonna um I wanted to
give a shout out to Hi-Fi I'd like to
just point out our Short episode is 50
minutes long pretty impressive
um that uh just came out from Tango who
probably best known it's installing on
my Xbox right now so [__] cool wait
what is this oh Hi-Fi Rush it's a game
I've always wanted to make and I'm
annoyed with someone else so so so good
it so they they they're known for Evil
Within and also ghostwide Tokyo which is
actually like it makes a lot of sense if
you see them go Evil Within go so I took
you a Hi-Fi rush but very different
things and I always love seeing Studios
do that where like you know gorilla went
from making Kill Zone to making Horizon
it's so cool to see um so stylish so fun
so upbeat and just like makes you feel
very very cool while playing and it's on
the beat and you've got this protagonist
who's clicking and like stomping his
feet constantly is his animation it's so
so so cool I just wanted to give a quick
shout out to that before we let me wrap
up today totally check it out it's I
think about 12 hours I think it's on
Game Pass oh my god um very oh yeah
because it's Bethesda so it should be um
yeah it's it's [__] cool as hell like
just incredible and I love the big
studios of letting projects at that
scale happen that's an incredibly cool
Pence yeah I think that's a positive
game Boss yeah
and that is it's and knowing the so the
shape of Game Pass deals it makes sense
because there is it's similar to like
early Xbox Live arcade some kind of Xbox
Live arcade before the Indies arrive
what do you think what kind of stuff
Hi-Fi Rush of no pentiment Jesus Christ
well it was only 13 people
but to be honest making it in a big
Studio it's probably more
uh because there's a lot of overheads
yeah I think it was less than 13. I
think grounded was 13. and dependables I
don't remember when I need to talk to
Josh about it Oh my Jesus yeah it's two
mil sounds like so much but I don't even
understand how video game budgets work
because
somebody gives us money
yeah literally published the book on it
it's just it's just very confusing
because salaries and I don't know yeah
well yeah burn right man you know it's
very cute
play it on Steam decks all right it's
very very cool matches less than cash
flow do I want the deluxe edition what
does it get
um not sure wait I just got whatever was
on Game Pass but
um yeah we have to head off thank you
for watching everybody we will see you
next week
[Music]